yeah good morning john now most of the
freeway system is okay but we have a
complete closure because of a fatal
crash that occurred a couple of hours
ago
southbound i-11 at horizon drive traffic
is actually stopped
before that here's a live picture of the
scene nhp did allow the traffic that was
backed up there to get through on the
side but the freeway
is still closed this is southbound i-11
at horizon drive this gruesome
photograph tweeted by the nevada highway
patrol apparently a car
tried to get under a truck or whatever
happened so southbound 95
515 traffic is stopped at the 215
you're diverted to the westbound 215 or
to go east on lake mead
no idea when this is going to reopen
meanwhile the other traffic is the big
squeeze more than 95 515 is down to two
lanes in both directions between the
spaghetti bowl and eastern
now it's not a super deal during the
overnight hours but once we get
past 5 30 or 6 this is going to be a
trouble spot that you might think
about completely avoiding now you can
see the work that's going on there
basically some kind of a repaving or fix
up we're suggesting skipping the whole
thing
go north or south on eastern or las
vegas boulevard up to washington or
bonanza or down to charleston and skip
the 95-515